[Musique]
un bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de
tv 78 nous sommes le mercredi 17
novembre voici les titres
consulter un médecin généraliste sans
rendez vous et en visio une cabine de
télé consultation est accessible
désormais à plaisir à la maison des
familles flora tristan est la commune la
loi une société pour pallier la
désertification médicale et éviter
d'encombrer les urgences les violences à
l'encontre de la police et plus
généralement des forces de l'ordre se
banalise il ya quelques semaines de
nombreuses attaques et débordements
avaient été constatés dans la nuit
d'halloween quelle est la situation
comment expliquer ce phénomène françois
bersani est notre invité les le
secrétaire départemental du syndicat
unité sgp police et puis le couple
nathalie marquay jean pierre pernaut
réunis au chesnay rocancourt les époux
installés dans les yvelines était en
dédicace tous deux ont en ce moment une
actualité littéraire
et c'est en ce moment la semaine de le
ps l'éducation physique et sportive un
évènement pour promouvoir la pratique du
sport à l'école et on en parle tout à
l'heure dans ce journal
[Musique]
287 le nombre de médecins pour 100000
habitants dans les yvelines selon des
données de l'insee datant de 2018 pour
pallier la désertification médicale une
cabine de téléconsultation a fait son
apparition à plaisir elle permet d'avoir
accès à un médecin généraliste sans
rendez vous via une consultation en
visio mélanie poké et justine brasier
6500 euros par an c'est le coût de
location de cette borne de
téléconsultations médicales à plaisir
une technologie inaugurée ce mardi 16
novembre pour répondre à la
problématique de désertification
médicale ce service permet de mettre en
relation patient et médecin objectif
éviter d'encombrer les urgences
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de médecins
généralistes disponibles le rendez vous
se déroule en visio une habitude depuis
la crise sanitaire
l'accord vise aussi à fait que
aujourd'hui on est on est on est moins
peut-être aller dans des endroits
encombré où il ya beaucoup de monde qui
fait la queue champ pour des choses
assez grave bien sûr donc ça c'est une
possibilité qui offre une liberté et
puis aussi une confidentialité qui est
importante une personne est présente au
côté de la machine le but accompagner
les patients dans leurs démarches et
désinfecter le matériel c'est bien que
quelqu'un soit là d'abord pour nettoyer
désinfecter là les petits appareils qui
sont mis à disposition et puis aussi
parce que il faut pas que les personnes
ne soient en peluche de leurs petites
pathologies je dirais inquiète par
rapport à cette mèche technologie de la
société medad hommes la borne est
implantée à la maison des familles flora
tristan dans une salle dédiée un rendez
vous est possible toutes les 10 minutes
en moyenne grâce à une centaine de
médecins partenaires vous arrivez donc
avec votre carte vitale
une carte bleue un numéro de portable
pour pouvoir vous connecter à votre
compte et la téléconsultation vont
pouvoir démarrer vous allez vous
retrouver face à un médecin en chair et
en os certes derrière un écran mais qui
va donc pouvoir établir un diagnostic et
vous donner une réponse médicale une
consultation prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale elle reste à la charge
du patient 7 euros 50 à l'occasion de la
semaine de la mobilité
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisé son
tout premier challenge vélo du 16
septembre 15 octobre est le but
encourager le développement de la
pratique du vélo par les salariés
travaillant dans l'agglomération trois
challenges était proposé aux salariés à
la remise des prix se dérouler en début
de semaine à l'hôtel d'agglomération
attrape merck airbus cpm au total sept
entreprises se sont lancées dans ce défi
pour limiter leur empreinte carbone
l'objectif il est multiple objectif il
est d'abord de faire en sorte que les
saint quentinois s'approprie et on va
dire se projette vers cette mobilité
propre durable qui est le vélo
évidemment que derrière il ya aussi des
impératifs en tout cas des des
répercussions environnementales
positives comme notamment la démission
la diminution de co2 et on l'a vu là
avec ses seize mille cinq cents
kilomètres parcourus dans le cadre du
challenge ces trois tonnes de co2 en
moins et parmi les lauréats deux
salariés de cpm ont remporté le prix du
meilleur cycliste car ils ont effectué
le plus grand nombre de trajets est deux
d'airbus ont gagné le prix du meilleur
rouleur car les ont parcouru le plus
grand nombre de kilomètres et enfin
merck qui s'illustre en tant que
meilleure entreprise cyclistes car elle
enregistre le plus grand nombre de
trajets par rapport au nombre total de
salariés est la réaction au micro de
mathilde franck où on était une équipe
qui était bien motivé le china jose a
bien motivés en premier le vélo 2 de
pluie comme parent puis comme barbotan
et on était en était une bonne équipe on
sait bien on sait bien motivés les uns
les autres
[Musique]
tirs de mortiers jets de pierres sur des
patrouilles ou des commissariats les
forces de l'ordre sont très
régulièrement prise à partie dans les
yvelines de nombreuses tensions ont été
recensés notamment le soirée d'halloween
biche et emea santisteva nous fait le
point sur la situation dans le
département en 2020 on a recensé en
france 27 1659 cas de violences à
l'encontre de policiers c'est deux fois
plus que lors de l'année 2001 chiffres
malgré tout en baisse par rapport à 2010
neuf années de gilet jaune mais comment
se manifeste cette animosité dans les
yvelines le fait le plus récent aux
clayes-sous-bois deux jeunes de 17 et 20
ans ont été arrêtés après avoir attaqué
la police le 27 octobre dernier une
attaque organisée l'un lance un caillou
sur le véhicule pour briser la vitre
l'autre tente de tirer un mortiers
d'artifice à l'intérieur le verdict est
tombé le 9 novembre dernier pour le plus
âgé d'entre 30 mois de prison dont six
avec sursis
le cas du second est toujours sous
investigation du juge préférant garder
le silence il a été incarcéré en maison
d'arrêt en attendant le jugement il a
été également mise en cause pour vol en
réunion sous la menace d'une arme et vol
avec effraction mais la nuit la plus
représentative de ces agissements et la
nuit d'halloween 2021 où plus d'une
dizaine d'incidents ont été enregistrés
dans le département à elancourt les
mureaux trappe aubergenville ou encore
montigny le bretonneux
cela se caractérise surtout par des tirs
de mortiers envers les patrouilles mais
aussi des poubelles enflammées et des
jets de pierres contacté par notre
rédaction la gendarmerie des yvelines
n'a pas souhaité répondre préférant
attendre la fin des procédures en cours
culture anti flics tension entraînée par
le kobe 19 ou encore escalade de la
violence les hypothèses sont nombreuses
pour tenter d'expliquer ces phénomènes
pour rappel une dizaine de policiers et
gendarmes sont tués en mission en france
chaque année ils étaient onze en 2020
françois bersani m'a rejoint un plateau
bonsoir bonsoir fait le secrétaire
départemental du syndicat unité sgp
police or ce thème des violences
urbaines et qui visent les forces de
l'ordre revient beaucoup dans
l'actualité ces dernières semaines on se
souvient forcément de ce tableau des
primes qui a été découvert dans une dans
un hall d'immeuble du 77 qui promettait
des récompenses pour abattre des
policiers violer des policiers c'est un
phénomène qui a tendance à se banaliser
ces derniers temps alors malheureusement
oui les attaques envers les forces de
l'ordre ne font que s'amplifier les
violences urbaines vont c'est un
phénomène déjà assez assez vieux par
exemple là sur cette année 2021 rien que
depuis le mois d'avril entre avril et ce
jour nous avons eu 800 faits de
violences urbaines sur ce département
des yvelines ce qu'on appelle les
violences urbaines s'est aussi bien dans
des incendies de mobilier urbain de
véhicules mais aussi toutes les attaques
envers les forces de l'ordre mais pas
que ça peut être des attaques sur des
bus des attaques sur des pompiers
aujourd'hui toutes les nuits quasiment
dans les yvelines alors il ya des pics
je vois j'entendais un reportage vous
avez des pays que le 13 juillet vous
avez des piques que 31 octobre pour
halloween ou pour la saint sylvestre
mais aujourd'hui toutes les nuits vous
avez des policiers qui sont agressés
alors il ya des villes qui vraiment
plaintive ce phénomène menthe les
mureaux poissy sartrouville trappe mais
aujourd'hui vous avez des communes qui
ne faisait pas parler d'elle comme la
celle saint cloud comme le montigny le
bretonneux donc ça se généralise à
l'ensemble du département sur l'ensemble
des circonscriptions aujourd'hui tout à
fait parce qu'aujourd'hui à l'autorité
de l'état n'est plus respectée on va
dire que l'état de droit est en berne
pas seulement sur ce département j'ai
les échos de mes collègues des autres
départements de la grande couronne
francilienne c'est c'est pareil
aujourd'hui vous avez une mauvaise
couverture de la voie publique par la
police nationale par manque d'effectif
il faut savoir qu'entre 2010 et 2020 sur
ce département des yvelines pour un
million deux cent mille habitants en
zone police nous avons perdu trois cents
policiers de deux voies publiques il ya
eu des annonces qui ont été faites on y
reviendra bien d'autres mais aujourd'hui
on paye on paye là le manque de
couverture de la voie publique par les
forces de police malgré toute la bonne
volonté qu'ils ont j'allais vous
demander beaucoup de faire recenser ces
dernières semaines vous le dit quasiment
tous les soirs il ya des faits de
violence oui vous avez vous avez des
faits de violences urbaines tous les
soirs alors ça aussi de deux à six par
nuit avec des pics à 30 comme le soir du
31 octobre mais tous les soirs
malheureusement nos espions des jets de
projectiles mortier cocktails molotov
comme telle moto a fait un peu moins
souvent mais les projectiles et les tirs
de mortier ça s est constant comment on
peut l'expliquer il ya plusieurs
hypothèses qui sont qui sont soulevés
mais qu' il ya une recrudescence
justement ce ce phénomène est bien
écouté alors que dans la rue des censes
par quoi elle s'explique parce que
d'abord il n'ya pas la peur il ya pas la
peur du policier ou du gendarme
aujourd'hui pourquoi n'y a pas cette
peur parce que on en revient toujours au
vieux serpent de mer de la réponse
pénale aujourd'hui les personnes qui
attaquent des policiers ou des pompiers
ou des soignants ou des élus ou des
professeurs ne sont pas sanctionnés
comme ils le devraient alors on a
tendance en france à créer de nouvelles
infractions en haussant les peines mais
le problème c'est pas la lourdeur de la
peine c'est la certitude de la peine est
aujourd'hui cette certitude de la paix
n'existe pas quand vous commettez un
délit vous avez plus de chance de ne pas
être inquiété que d'être inquiétées on
parlera tout à l'heure de la réponse
pénale puisqu'un projet de loi est en ce
moment en cours d'adoption est ce que
depuis les confinements les
comportements ont changé est ce que vous
avez aussi observés çà où finalement on
reste sur une tendance plutôt similaires
depuis ces confinement on reste sous une
tendance lourde faut savoir que pendant
les confinements on avait assisté par
exemple à une recrudescence des
violences intrafamiliales violences
conjugales mais aujourd'hui tous les
soirs vous avez des individus qui sont
interpellés quand il eut principalement
des hommes qui sont interpellées pour
des faits de violence decaux conjugale
ça n'a pas cessé avec le confinement
c'était déjà présents avant le
confinement d'en parler peut-être un peu
mois avec la libération de la parole et
la création par exemple d'une plateforme
à guyancourt de national de violences
sexistes et sexuelles et beaucoup
beaucoup de communication aussi du
gouvernement sur ce sujet mais
aujourd'hui non il a tendance lourde à
et à la montée des chiffres en matière
de délinquance vous parliez tout à
l'heure de ses 300 fonctionnaires qui
sont partis de ce département des
yvelines en dix ans et en avril dernier
le ministre de l'intérieur et gérald
darmanin a annoncé un renfort policier
sur le département 128 qui ne concerne
pas toutes les circonscriptions
d'ailleurs on avait couvert et vous
étiez présent ce rassemblement des
maires de la circonscription de plaisir
qui demandait à l'époque aussi des
renforts ce qui n'était pas concerné par
ces annonces finalement quatre policiers
ont été annoncés par la suite est ce que
ces renforts sont arrivés déjà
aujourd'hui dans le département eh bien
écoutez grégory on assiste là à
la technique numéro un c'est l'effet
d'annoncé c'est à dire qu'on a annoncé
en effet cent vingt-quatre policiers sur
le département mais ça n'est pas un
solde positif puisqu'en fait entre les
chiffres du nombre de policiers en
décembre 2020 et au à fin octobre nous
avons eu quatre policiers en plus sur le
département des yvelines pourquoi parce
qu'en fait certes on a essayé de faire
venir 124 policiers mais dans le même
temps vous avez eu les départs naturels
alors les départs naturels ce sont les
départs à la retraite ce sont des
passerelles vers d'autres métiers et
c'est surtout les mutations vers la
province qui ont totalement annihilé
l'effort des 124 alors maintenant on
fait la différence aujourd'hui a que
quatre policiers supplémentaires le 31
décembre 2020 et le 1er octobre 2021
vous avez quatre policiers de voie
publique gardiens et gradés en plus sur
le département alors maintenant on a eu
connaissance d'un nouveau renfort sur
les yvelines à peu près 80 12 policiers
qui devrait arriver entre le 20 décembre
et le 1er janvier mais comme dans la
foulée de ce mouvement va arriver il va
y avoir des mouvements de départ en
finale on va retomber à une situation
qui sera guère plus satisfaisante si on
se revoit six mois après 7,6 mois après
le 1er janvier 2022 aujourd'hui a pas de
tendance lourde est constante
d'augmenter le nombre de policiers c'est
du one shot on saupoudre un peu par ci
un peu par là mais dans le même temps il
ya des départs on comprend que c'est ça
reste insuffisant pourquoi justement au
quotidien vous avez besoin de ces
renforts pourquoi ils sont primordiaux
pour les policiers et bien parce
qu'aujourd'hui même si nos gouvernants
pense qu'on va tout régler avec des
algorithmes avec de la vidéo protection
avec des moyens techniques d'aujourd'hui
la police elle se fait encore par
l'humain sur la voie publique on n'a pas
trouvé de méthode pour interpeller des
auteurs de crimes ou délits sans la
présence de policiers le gouvernement
misait aussi sur le continuum de
sécurité un terme un peu techno qui veut
dire qu'on fait travailler en gros la
police municipale les polices
municipales en complément de la police
nationale mais sur les yvelines c'est
très hétéro hétéroclite vous n'avez pas
des polices municipales très équipée
partout dans le département donc il ya
encore beaucoup de circonscriptions
police où c'est la police nationale qui
doit assumer les interventions et quand
vous êtes sur des secteurs avec
seulement cinq six policiers en police
secours à l'instant t eh bien vous
souffrez de questions sur la réponse
pénale peut être plus forte en tout cas
c'est l'objectif d'un projet de loi qui
s'appelle responsabilité pénale et
sécurité intérieure il a été adopté en
première lecture par les députés c'était
en septembre il crée une infraction peu
spécifique au code pénal sur les
violences contre les forces de l'ordre
ça concerne aussi notamment les
policiers les gendarmes mais aussi les
sapeurs pompiers par exemple avec des
peines qui peuvent aller jusqu'à sept
ans d'emprisonnement cent mille euros
damende est-ce que ça va dans le bon
sens et pas encore suffisant je vous
parlais et d'algorithmes de l'effet
d'annoncé paresse et de l'effet
d'annoncé alors vous allez vous dire que
vous allez dire que je condamne ou jeudi
hawtin toutes les annonces qui sont
faites mais en l'occurrence nous ce qui
nous intéresse c'est la certitude de la
peine à savoir qu'un délinquant ou un
criminel est sûr qu'il va hériter d'une
peine la lourdeur de la peine c'est
quasiment accessoires aujourd'hui vous
pouvez aggravé les peines qui sont
prévues tant qu'elles ne sont pas
prononcés par les juges du siège ça ne
sert à rien et aujourd'hui le problème
c'est que nous on réclame des peines
automatiques des peines incompressibles
des peines minimum on appelle ça comme
on veut plancher minimum automatique
pour garantir en effet qui est incertain
quantum de la peine qui sera prononcée
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez dire va
mieux on va punir de 10 ans mais si dans
les eaux tribunal judiciaire de
versailles les affaires qui passe écope
de 3 à 6 mois de prison ça ne sert à
rien d'augmenter à indéfiniment le
maximum de la peine merci françois
bersani d'être venu en plateau et je
rappelle vous êtes le secrétaire
départemental du syndicat unité sgp
police 78
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également l'inquiétude
des salariés de sté lantiss le géant de
l'automobile réuni cent ans psa et fiat
chrysler va regrouper ses équipes en
ile-de-france à poissy sur son futur des
greens campus qui sera opérationnel
d'ici 2024 plus de 2500 personnes sur
les 4000 employés du site de vélizy
devrait donc déménagé à l'appel d'une
intersyndicale et des salariés se sont
rassemblés ce mardi à la mi journée pour
dénoncer ce déménagement entre 1300 et
1500 selon les syndicats 250 selon là
direction du groupe ils craignent un
allongement considérable de leur temps
de trajet des pertes d'emplois à terme
ce que réfute la direction de ces
lentilles ce jusqu'à vendredi c'est la
semaine de l'éducation physique et
sportive organisée par le syndicat snes
fsu dans les yvelines une réunion sur le
ps et le sport hors scolaire est
programmée à la maison des familles de
trappes ce jeudi l'objectif c'est de
faire prendre conscience de l'importance
du sport pour les jeunes interview
express par célia 200 go
on dans les yvelines il a été décidé de
prendre le thème du sport du sport
scolaire et le ps et les interactions
qu'il y ait entre entre ces différents à
différentes disciplines et ses
différents milieux de manière à
favoriser le développement d'une
jeunesse ce plus sportif
c'est nous faire connaître à faire
connaître notre discipline parce qu'on
se rend compte que depuis quelques
années elle a été un petit peu attaqué
un par les différents ministères en
l'occurrence un ya par exemple eu des
preuves spécifique de ps au niveau du
brevet des collèges au niveau du dnb il
ya lui aussi au niveau du bac avec la
réforme la dernière réforme des lycées
l'importance de le ps a été minorée et
pourtant c'est la seul acte de la seule
discipline qui est présente de la 6ème
jusqu'à la terminale quelles que soient
les filières
l'activité physique et sportive est
fondamental selon moi donc ça fait
partie bien sûr des disciplines
obligatoires à l'école non c'est
important pour la santé pour
l'épanouissement de nos élèves pour pour
leur faire acquérir une culture sportive
bien évidemment à puisque pas plus on va
être en capacité à l'école d'apprendre
de choses dans les différentes activités
sportives et artistiques plus nos élèves
auront à coeur ou ou oseront davantage
aller dans les clubs sportifs pratiquer
des activités en dehors que ce soit
voilà le savoir nager un 100 fait partie
bien évidemment en moyenne l'air
intérieur et sept à huit fois plus
pollué que l'air extérieur c'est en
partant de ce constat qu'une société
yvelinoise commercialise un
décontaminateur et purificateurs d'air
capable de tuer bactéries allergènes ou
encore les virus une idée qui fait son
chemin en ces temps de pandémie le
reportage à buchelay de mathilde franco
créé en 2015 dans le but de limiter la
propagation de la grippe le air clean de
sang a également prouvé son efficacité
en tant de kovy 19 son action est rendu
possible grâce à un réacteur testé et
approuvé par plusieurs centres de
recherche dont le cnrs donc là je vous
faire voir l'éclaté de la machine avec
son fonctionnement
donc là en fait l'air est aspiré par un
ventilateur
freiner dans notre réacteur qui est 8
bombardaient de l'ue vers et après l'or
l'air ressort des contaminés on a mis un
petit filtre de l'avant mais c'est
simplement pour le atténué en fait la
luminosité de l'avant et pour des
raisons de sécurité et d'environnement
une lampe uv a est utilisé plus vert
pourquoi parce que les uv c aujourd'hui
génère de l'ozone donc s'ils ont des
contamines avec un duvet c'est les
personnes peuvent pas rester dans la
pièce alors qu'avec notre équipement
vous pouvez décontaminer toute la
journée les personnes peuvent rester
dans la pièce mais décontaminateur air
clean de s'en est vendu à 550 euros hors
taxes principalement à destination des
lieux de fort passage écoles ou ehpad
est des invités de marque au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les all blacks sont venus taper quelques
balles ce matin sur l'albatros célèbre
parcours de la ryder cup 2018 et 12
joueurs parmi lesquels damian mackenzie
et idji père et nara séance détente au
programme pour les rugbymen
néo-zélandais à trois jours du choc face
au quinze de france les deux nations se
retrouvent pour le dernier test match de
la tournée d'automne au stade de france
samedi à 21h la semaine dernière les
bleus l'ont emporté contre la géorgie
les all blacks ont perdu en irlande en
boxe on connaît désormais le prochain
adversaire de tony yoka l'athlète de 29
ans originaires de chanteloup les vignes
sera opposé à carlos takam le 15 janvier
à l'accord hôtel arena à paris le 20e
mondial tentera d'obtenir une 12e
victoire en autant de combat chez les
poids lourds en professionnel face à
luis carlos takam au 23e rang mondial
âgé de 40 ans il a déjà affronté les
britanniques anthony joshua et jojoy
s'inclinant de peu à chaque fois c'est
le haut niveau mondial un gros cap pour
moi a confié l'yvelinois à l'équipe tony
yoka qui s'est fixé comme objectif de
conquérir une ceinture mondiale dans les
prochains mois un couple de
personnalités de sortie dans le
département jean pierre pernaut et
nathalie marquay était aux chaînés
rocancourt à la librairie le bal en crin
c'était samedi dernier une séance de
dédicaces et rencontres avec leurs
lecteurs mélanie poké et bixente manas
entité panne
ce simple fait de temps en temps c'est
la deuxième fois seulement cette année
on a écrit moi j'ai écrit mon livre il
ya un an on a fait plus que dédicaces
avec la crise est au coeur présentateur
emblématique du journal de 13 heures
jean-pierre pernaut était ce samedi 13
novembre dans la librairie le bain
d'encre aux chaînés rocancourt pour une
séance de dédicaces de quoi rendre
nostalgique certains visiteurs c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait découvrir des
régions à mes parents et pendant leurs
vacances il allait donc dans les régions
qu'ils ont découvert grâce au soutient
monsieur pernaut en fait ça fait depuis
des années qu on le regarde à la télé le
tf 1 est donc pour nous c'est un
monsieur sacré journalistes avec lui
nathalie marquay-pernaut sa femme elle
présentait son nouveau livre moi j'y
crois je crois à mésanges à mes guides
je fais des rêves prémonitoires donc je
peux que y croit dans mon livre je
raconte aussi que jamais eu la date de
la mort du frère de jean-pierre donc
grâce à moi il a que lui dire un dernier
adieu tient un livre étonnant pour une
personnalité connue parce que les gens
n'osent pas parler de ces des rapports
avec l'au delà des prémonitions des
pressentiments des anges etc et elle
raconte tout ce qu'elle vit au quotidien
habitant dans les yvelines le couple est
familier de sa librairie locale ils
viennent dans un temps ici j'aime mais
j'aime bien
pas assez souvent malheureusement mais
c'est vrai que quand j'avais dit kai et
les stylos acheté pour mes enfants c'est
toujours ici que je vais je viens c'est
donc naturellement que l'ancienne miss
france 1987 est venu rencontrer ses
lecteurs pour faire découvrir son
quatrième ouvrage
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant nouveau
numéro du 7 8 sociétés mélanie poké
parle ce soir avec ses invités est de
ces commune yvelinoise qui ont fait le
choix de passer aux 30 km heure belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]
or